uh the cowboys have a choice when it
comes to the quarterback position and
their choice is to stick with dak
prescott and a report came over over the
weekend regarding
the latest offer the cowboys have made
and it was strange to me because it
wasn't couched the way maybe it could
have been or should have been calvin
watkins of the dallas morning news
reported that the cowboys have offered
33 million per year to dak prescott now
there was a report back in september
they offered 33 million per year but
that's a different analysis then because
33 million in new money when he's in the
last year of his rookie contract
that's about 28 million at signing based
upon what he made last year which was
two million dollars right now
33 million per year now when he has no
contract when there is no new money when
it's total value with signing of 33
million chris russell wilson who is the
highest paid quarterback right now in
the nfl at 35 million a year in new
money the value of his deal at signing
was 31.4
dak prescott currently can be if he
wants to be the highest paid player in
nfl history and so far he hasn't
accepted that contract that would put
him ahead of russell wilson yeah well i
i'm uh i'm surprised i can't lie about
it i mean if this report is real and we
have no reason to think it's not at this
point
you know i would think that this would
be a deal that dak prescott wants to
take i just you know again you know i'm
totally always in the player you're the
same way as me we're on the side of the
player the billionaire has billions
already the player only has so many
years to strike and i'm all for them
trying to get the all the money they can
but man you know what what what it what
at face value wouldn't you like about
this deal and if i'm dak prescott again
now with this type of you know talk or
rumor or evidence that coming out that
he's being offered this you know he's
gonna creep down the road here of
looking a little selfish if he doesn't
be careful here and continue to squeak
if he continues to squeeze them for more
and more money is what i'm saying that's
all i'm saying there let me let me add
this though yeah okay the report is 33
million per year
plus 105 million guaranteed now that
doesn't tell us how much is fully
guaranteed it's signing which is one of
the key metrics and the signing bonus is
the most important because that's the
money that you earn the moment you put
your name on the document right fully
guaranteed salary that's almost as good
fully guaranteed roster bonuses in
future years that's almost as good the
signing bonus fully guaranteed is the
thing they can never take away because
you earn that money the moment you put
your name on the contract but we don't
know like you know
aaron rodgers has less total guaranteed
money than russell wilson but aaron
rodgers has significantly more that was
fully guaranteed at signing right in
russell wilson but almost 10 million
dollars so the devil is going to be in
those details and we don't know what
those details are all right they are um
and and you know the other side of it
too is if you got a bunch of fake phony
years at the back end they can drive up
the average value of a deal what's the
cash flow year one two and three like if
all of a sudden the contract is jacked
up to 50 million a year in years four
five and six that's going to drive up
the average but he's never going to make
that money so that's part of it too so
we need to know more about it and also
chris you're right
his leverage right now is the franchise
tag yeah and if the cowboys are going to
apply the exclusive franchise tag
they're going to have to offer him more
than 31 million this year alone with the
promise of a 20 raise next year and
that's what he is comparing this offer
to sure i can get nearly 70 million over
two years under the franchise tag why
would i trade that in for a long-term
deal that averages 33. so
again they allowed it to get to this
point this is on the cowboys and now dak
prescott is using his leverage to the
fullest and he has every right to do it
and i fully support it and if the
because the the alternative is don't use
the franchise tag and let him go to the
market let the market decide what he's
worth maybe he's not worth 33 million
there's only one way to find out and if
the cowboys don't like it if the fans
don't like it then maybe that's what
they should do well the the benefit too
i mean to what you're saying and you're
right i mean the formula they're using
whether the exclusive you know franchise
tag this year then the 20 the next year
but the argument they also could make is
that hey we're going to guarantee you
more money substantially more money you
know than that 70 million all together
and you're gonna get that now you might
it might take three or four years
whatever it may be but it is more
long-term security that's what the
cowboys ownership can at least say there
about that now you know this to me this
is to me one of the problems of the nfl
right now again and i love dak prescott
you know that i love the guy i totally
think he's the franchise for the dallas
cowboys but within saying i think he's
the franchise for the dallas cowboys at
the quarterback position i also don't
think he's in the class of watson
mahomes rogers wilson i don't think he's
there and this is to me where the owners
have really screwed it up to where i
just don't understand
where you know they've let it be where
the next guy up always signs the richest
contract like right now russell wilson
should just be the highest paid
quarterback
and that should be it nobody should get
more money than that nobody what about
the homes until my home signs right
until my home signs and that's the kind
of guy that deserves to be that you know
and to me that's where the owners have
botched just a little bit because
they've led players to believe that if
you're even in the top 10 conversation
at your position when it's your time to
sign you're going to one-up everybody
and become the richest at that position
in the history and that to me is where
it's gone wrong at the quarterback
market and gotten skewed and gone crazy
i mean the fact that we were saying the
words derek carr is the richest
player in the history of the nfl is
insane the fact that we were saying
jimmy garoppolo is like the highest paid
quarterback in football
is insane that's insanity didn't last
long i know didn't last long but it's
still cousins was the next one i won
this later well right and i want to
curse about that too because that is
freaking insane that their names are
ever above some of the other people at
that time or right now that are truly in
the elite cream of the crop category and
that's something that needs to get
corrected here too and you know i'm all
for dak prescott getting his money but i
also just want to see the guy succeed
and be successful and i kind of root for
him and i want some money left over go
ahead it's jumping it's too late it's
it's it's too it's too late it's too
late you've already done the damage
you're never gonna interview prescott
again we're never gonna get derek carr
on the show not that we had a chance
anyway here's two things that happened
yeah one
tom brady
in never maxing out what he could earn i
think kept the market from being what it
could be because when you get the
absolute top dollar for the best guy in
the sport the other guys fall in line
behind making a heck of a lot more than
they would be making without tom brady
stretching the rubber band as far as he
can as far as he can and i think it's
also harder to justify paying
quarterbacks more when the guy who's
clearly the best quarterback is
consciously choosing less sure you know
the the other side of this coin um is
that aaron rodgers committed to an ultra
long-term deal through 2019 and there
were several years where the market just
stagnated right because it was him and
joe flacco at the top and drew brees was
in that mix as well but it wasn't really
growing and it started with andrew luck
then derek carr then jimmy garoppolo
then kirk cousins and matt ryan then
then
aaron rodgers then russell wilson and
ben roethlisberger's kind of wedged in
there between rogers and wilson but it
really started to happen in fast
succession and now i think it's
flattening out a little bit and part of
the challenge is figuring out where dak
prescott fits let me throw this one at
you yeah um
and we we've seen how quickly
circumstances can change one week ago
today
the thought of tom brady possibly
playing for the 49ers was inconceivable
but dion sanders kept banging the drum
peter king picked up the other stick and
was banging it as well you and i started
talking about it then tom curran got in
on the act karen gorigen of the boston
herald was in on it and then it becomes
a thing right it has life yeah so here
we are this monday we're a week away
from tom brady becoming a free agent and
all this talk of the 49ers possibly
getting him 49ers possibly getting 49ers
possibly getting him so he's coming to
the nfc
at what point at what point does
you know
what point does jerry jones say enough
with dak
i'm gonna go get tom brady and i'm gonna
go all in and i'm gonna load up the can
and i'm getting in on this if he's
coming to the nfc he's coming to the
cowboys could that
could that pop up out of nowhere this
week like the 49ers seemingly popped up
out of nowhere last week oh i would be
shocked i just can't imagine you know
you know it's it's a it's a there's more
questions about the cowboys right now i
mean we all see the talent on their
roster but we got to see somebody kind
of like put it all together and you know
make a you mean like mike mccarthy oh
yeah exactly we got to see him do it you
know and then also i would argue to that
fact if i was like having to talk to
jerry jones and stuff i would go man all
right i know you want to win a super
bowl and all that you bring brady to
town though there's a very real
possibility that you're putting yourself
in if i don't win it this year then
we're i'm not going to win it and i'm
going to put we're going to take two or
three steps back maybe if he decides to
retire after this year or you know
father time really catches up with him
at 43 and we still really see a drop off
whoa then hey mr jones 2021 your
season's ruined and now you're probably
gonna have to wait two or three more
years to rebuild the team a little bit
and find another quarterback to lead you
to the super bowl so that would be the
risk i would argue to them to where dak
prescott you know you sign him up he
gives you the super bowl window is open
for a number of years going forward here
and we've talked about jerry's not
christmas they were eight and eight last
year right that's the thing okay but i
know they have a new coach now but what
has dak press got done from a wins and
losses standpoint to make you think the
super bowl window's open when they
didn't even get to the playoffs last
year because i don't look at anything as
far as dak prescott i look at things
like going man this defense with all
this talent never dominates a good
offense never they just let teams go up
and down the field and then i go damn
here we are at the end of the year and
there's no motions or no shifts again
and nobody's capitalizing on anything on
the offensive side of the ball i didn't
look at it and go damn dak prescott's
really holding the cowboys back if they
had somebody else no i don't say that in
fact i found myself saying that more
about tom brady and the patriots than i
did dak prescott in the dallas cowboys
where i went some games and said damn
tom tom did not help the team out in
this game
as i've mentioned here before this year
you could prop like this was the first
year ever we could sit here and go brady
didn't win one game for the patriots
this year he was good i'm not trying to
like sit here and crap on tom brady but
there's this is the first year of his
career where i can sit here and look at
all 16 games and go there's not one game
i can look at and go man if they didn't
have tom brady there's no way they win
that game all right so that to me
that there's something to that as well
as far as where tom's at in his career
and look i i i think that that the world
is different than it was when the
cowboys were trying to find tony romo
and they all i mean when they were
trying to find a good quarterback and
they found tony romo undrafted they got
dak prescott in round four i think it's
easier to find quarterbacks now than
back when they were flailing around
between troy aikman and tony romney yes
you're right and and and and i think
look i jerry jones is so much about now
now now i just i'm just trying to
discern i know whether or not all this
smoke that is pointing toward tom brady
to san francisco would be enough when
you consider that dak prescott is saying
no thank you to 33 million per year
where's the point where jerry says
screw it right
let's go get tom brady let's put him in
number 12 if roger staubach says it's
okay and we've we've given you a chance
folks to see what it looks like we have
the photographic evidence of tom brady
in the cowboys uniform there it is there
it is with starbucks number and his body
and everything but like his eyes
pretty much
bring back the old two bar face mask too
and that would make it awesome but mike
you made the right point like the right
point is yes we're hearing about the dak
prescott contract and 33 million a year
and new money high but we really we
don't you know we don't know it's
propaganda at this point we don't know
any of the details the guaranteed money
the signing bonus or the guarantee that
signing all that could be far less than
what's acceptable for you know a guy
like dak prescott too so until we hear
all those type of numbers you know i'm
not going to sit here and and yell at
dak prescott and say how could you not
take this offer
and maybe this leak
maybe this leak was aimed not at
pressuring him to take it but poisoning
the well just a little bit in the event
that at some point this week jerry jones
decides all these quarterbacks out there
whether it's tom brady or anybody else
i'm going all in with somebody else we
don't know what mike mccarthy thinks of
dak prescott and he's not going to tell
us what he thinks that dak prescott no
but there's a lot of factors here i'm
not ruling out anything and i want chaos
so i'm inclined to say these things
but i i'm
i don't rule out anything when it comes
to the cowboys and jerry jones because
he wants to win now and they were eight
and eight last year and a new coach may
not be enough in his view to get them
over the top
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports